my name is Chelsea Finn I'm a professor
at Stanford today I've been challenged
to explain a topic and five levels of
difficulty
today we're talking about moravex
Paradox which says that the things that
are really really easy and second nature
for humans are actually really difficult
to program into AI systems and robots
it's an important topic because it means
that when we program robots some of the
really basic stuff that we take for
granted is actually quite difficult
[Music]
hi I'm Chelsea what's your name Juliet
nice to meet you Juliet today we'll talk
a little bit about a concept called more
of X Paradox what's that something that
explains what's hard and what's easy for
a robot something like stacking these
two cups do you think that's easy or
hard if it's this way then it's easy but
if it's this way you need to balance it
or oh it's still pretty easy right it
turns out that stocking these two cups
it's actually really hard for robots to
do that so let's think about how we
might have a robot stock these two cups
you could program the robot to move its
hand right here and then program the
robot to close its hand around the cup
and then program the robot to move over
here and open it and drop it exactly
right
just
that seemed pretty simple for the robot
to do say we even just moved the cup
over here do you think the robot would
still be able to stack the cups
yes we can see what happens
so it's gonna We program the robot to
move to the same exact position as
before oh yeah so it goes to the same
place when we gave it instructions Did
we tell it to look at where the cup was
or did we tell it to just move over here
we told it to just move over here
exactly so more of EX Paradox is
something that means that these really
simple things like stocking cups is
really really hard for robots even
though it's really easy for us while
robots are actually really good at
really complicated and really difficult
things think about the task of
multiplying two really big numbers
together okay okay does that seem like a
hard task or an easy task
it's easy for me you either get at
multiplying big numbers together yes
could you multiply 4 100 by no I can't
do that but it's actually really easy
for a computer to do that so how fast
were you able to stack the two cups like
two seconds it took me like a couple of
days when I learned how to stack cups
yeah but so it took you a couple days
when you learned how to stock cups but
before that you already knew how to
grasp objects right you already knew how
to pick out cups and so you could use
that when you were learning the stock
codes we're trying to be inspired by how
humans learn to do tasks to allow robots
to do the same kind of things that are
very simple for people like stocking
cups we want robots to be able to do
something like that too
what grade are you in I
a junior have you heard of something
called more Vex Paradox never heard of
it typically you would think that things
that are easy for humans are also easy
for robots and computers to do right and
things that are hard for humans should
also be hard for robots and humans to do
but it turns out that it's actually the
opposite I want to try a little demo so
I have a penny in my hand and I'd like
you to pick it up with your right hand
and put it into your left hand
so that was pretty easy right yeah we're
gonna make this a little bit harder now
so can you put these on and we'll try to
do the same thing again with your eyes
closed
foreign
there you go let's try that one more
time and see if you can do any better so
close your eyes
oh there we go yeah so that you're with
a bit more practice you're able to
figure it out when it fell on the ground
how did you know to pick it up off the
ground from the Sun so when a robot
tries to do something like pick up an
object not only do you need to program
exactly like what the motors should do
the robot also needs to be able to see
where the object is then this is what's
called a perception action Loop in
robotics so if the object moves the
robot can then adapt what it's doing and
change what it's doing to successfully
pick up the object it's really important
for robots to be able to leverage not
just like the past hour of experience
but also ideally many years of
experience in order to do the kinds of
things that you did it's kind of hard
for me to understand why like robots can
do like all these crazy calculations but
they can't do like all the simple stuff
so yeah it's really unintuitive in order
to survive we need to pick up objects
and everything basically many many like
billions of years of evolution actually
created humans and the ability to
manipulate objects like that so it
actually turns out that things that are
really basic for us are actually just
really complex tasks in general so do
robots know like they messed up they
know that's a great question so in
reinforcement learning the robot tries
the task and then it gets some sort of
reinforcement some sort of feedback
similar to how you might train a dog
yeah so you could give it feedback like
that so it won't necessarily know itself
especially on the first few tries but
it's trying to figure out what the task
is even does a robot see like how we see
or does it like just see like a program
or something we give robots a camera and
the camera produces this array of
numbers basically each each pixel has
three different numbers one for R for G
and for B and so the robot sees this
really massive set of numbers and it has
to be able to figure out from that
massive set of numbers what is in the
world there's a number of different ways
to have the robot see but we use a
technique called neural networks that
tries to take in those big numbers and
form representations of the objects in
the world and where those objects are
can a robot ever go off the program it
depends on how you program the robot if
you program the robot to follow exact
emotions and follow a very specific
program then it won't go off that
program it will always do those actions
but if something unexpected happens that
the program wasn't designed to handle
then the robot might go off course I
think robots will take over the world
just being honest I think that robotics
is really really hard having robots do
even really basic stuff like pick up
objects is really really hard so if they
do take over the world I think it'll be
a very very very very long time
foreign
so today we'll talk a bit about Robotics
and machine learning and artificial
intelligence so have you heard of more
of EX Paradox I haven't heard of more
effects Paradox yeah that's what it's
called yeah yeah I haven't heard of it
before it describes something in AI
which is that things that are really
intuitive and easy for humans are
actually really difficult to build into
AI systems and on the flip side picking
up an object really simple for people
but it's actually really difficult to
build that into robotic systems so do
you have any experience working with
robots or other AI systems I did work
with robots but they weren't doing like
artificial intelligence type of stuff we
were just sending like instructions and
the robot would do like perform like a
simple task I wasn't so used to the
aspect of like teaching a computer how
to do stuff so I'm always on that other
end of like giving instructions more
focused on the data analysis and machine
learning aspect of it and how would you
just describe machine learning like in
one sentence
I'd say machine learning is giving like
feeding data to a program or to a
machine and they start to learn based
off of that data do you have any
thoughts on like what the data might
look like in a robotic setting if you
were to apply machine learning to robots
I think of like coordinates yeah exactly
one thing that my research has been
looking into is if we can have robots
learn from data we'll collect data from
the robot sensors if the robot has
sensors in its arm to figure out the
angle of one of its wrist for example
then we'll record that angle and all of
the robots experience will go into a
data set now if we wanted a robot to
solve a task like I don't know picking
up a cup and then maybe you want to pick
up a different cup if it only had the
data of picking up the first cup do you
think it would be able to perform well
on the second cup I don't think so I
feel like that might be a problem yeah
so there's this generalization Gap this
gap between what it was trained to do
and what it the new thing so what's like
the most complicated thing for a robot
to learn is it visit motion so you can
think of robot robotics is having two
core components one is perception being
able to see and feel and so forth and
action where the robot actually figures
out how to move its arm and both
components are really essential and both
components are quite difficult if you
train a perception system independently
of how to choose actions then it might
make errors in a way that mess up the
the system that selects actions and so
if you instead try to train these two
systems together to have it learn
perception and action for the goal of
solving these different tasks then the
robot can be more successful one thing
that's really difficult about robotics
is there actually isn't that much data
of robots in the world on the internet
there's all sorts of text Data all sorts
of image data that people upload and
write but there isn't a lot of data of
doing a simple thing like tying your
shoe for example because it's so basic
one challenge is even just getting data
sets that allow us to teach robots to do
these simple kinds of tasks do you think
that we'd be able to
kind of accelerate that process of
collecting data or do you think is it
the way that we've been collecting those
types of data sets is that is that
what's keeping us behind that's a great
question I think we should be able to
accelerate the data collection process
by having robots collect more data
autonomously on their own and by doing
that we might be able to overcome some
of the challenges of more of X Paradox
what are some common algorithms that are
used in these types of techniques as the
robot is learning Depot is a common
toolbox for addressing some of these
challenges because it allows us to
leverage large data sets and so deep
learning is basically corresponds to
methods for training these artificial
neural networks another common method
that comes up is reinforcement learning
a third kind of algorithm is meta
learning algorithms and these algorithms
learn not just from the most recent
experience on the current task but
leverage experience from other tasks and
and in the past and they're not just
completely separate we can combine the
aspects of these algorithms into a
single method that gets the benefits of
each of them
[Music]
what year are you in your PhD I'm just
finishing up my first year studying food
manipulation and also by manual
manipulations and just enabling robots
to have these capabilities so that
eventually we can use it in like a home
robot use case for example what are some
of the challenges that you've run into
when trying to work with robots and do
these tasks so I was really interested
in the problem of scooping Peas on a
plate they're relatively homogeneous but
when it came to more complex foods like
broccoli or deformable foods like tofu
that can crumble that gets a lot more
complex to simulate one thing I find
really fascinating about robotics is
that the things that are so simple for
us like feeding yourself broccoli is so
second nature to us are really hard for
robotics when you try to take a robot
and train it to do a task and simulation
and the simulation isn't perfectly
accurate it's really hard to actually
model the physics of how a tofu crumbles
right what algorithms do you think are
most promising for handling non-rigid
deformable objects and the other things
you been looking at for most of my past
work which have been relatively more
complex tasks I lean towards the
imitation learning type of algorithm
approach behavioral cloning and all that
mostly because if it's hard to simulate
an interaction with an object then I
think RL is harder to go with because
it's not as sample efficient as
imitation learning can be and a lot of
the times I'll be learning some high
level policy of what to do and then hard
coding a lot of the like action
Primitives that I want to select between
my tasks how can we get robots to learn
more efficiently or learn faster from my
experience it's a matter of how much
support you give the like robot when
it's learning one could be like a
narrower task range another is maybe
like also biasing the types of samples
that you're collecting can bias towards
interactions that are going to be useful
where the the hands actually interact
with each other rather than just off
doing their own things what have you
found to be like your go-to's between
the different styles I think I have a
somewhat similar perspective to you in
that if we provide more structure and
support and sort of forms of prior
knowledge or experience of the algorithm
that should make it more efficient and
so if we can acquire those kinds of
priors about the world and about
interaction from previous data Maybe
offline data then I think we should be
able to make learning of new tasks more
efficient it's similar to like skill
transfer style of things because some
skills are just repeatable like if I
know how to pick up a cylinder then
maybe I know also how to pick up a mug
yeah so you may not transfer the exact
strategy or the exact policy that the
robot takes but you should be able to
learn some general heuristics about
performing manipulation there's this gap
between the simulators that we have now
and what we actually experience in
reality so what do you think are
promising directions to to try out for
actually making our simulations match
reality more closely it's a really a
really hard problem a lot of simulators
they don't simulate the world to Define
enough time granularity to really
accurately capture things like skewering
an object for example one thing that I
think is promising is to try to not
build simulators entirely from first
principles from our knowledge of physics
but instead to look at real data and see
how real data might inform our
simulations and try to build allow
robots to build models of the world
build simulators of the world Based on
data and based on experiences there's a
little bit of a chicken and egg problem
because if we want to use simulators to
get lots of data and we also need data
to get good simulators then
there there's no way to get around this
so when you say building simulators that
don't rely on first principles
um are you saying like kind of like a
learn simulator we have all these videos
of humans interacting with the world and
that can be your like physics data that
you then use to inform when you're
building the simulator that's learning
based on those videos exactly I think we
can use machine learning to learn about
physics and to build these kinds of
physics simulators that's really cool
it's a cool idea
[Music]
so great to see you Mike thanks for
coming it's my pleasure so over the past
four levels we've been talking about
more of EX Paradox I'm curious to get
your perspective there are still a lot
of open questions for how to leverage
previous experience and learn
cumulatively over time you know it's
funny because I'm kind of at the heart a
developmental psychologist and so when
we talk about babies a lot of what we're
talking about is how they become human I
started to try to build computer models
of little tiny bits of babies cognition
and I would ask people and they'd say
you have to assume that you can
recognize objects because actually
recognizing objects is impossible and I
was like wait it's impossible what about
Ai and they're like that's that's really
hard why do you think it's so hard to
build these things into AI systems and
robots I guess if you think about a you
know a quintessentially human task like
playing chess or solving an arithmetic
problem things that other creatures just
don't do
when you're a human being you have to
learn that in cultural time and so
there's a limited amount of data you
have but if you're talking about seeing
the world interacting with the world
using your factors properly that's the
combination of this massive amount of
evolutionary time when you look at that
it's like the 56 games of Chess I played
in chess club that doesn't look like a
lot of training data you work so hard to
make a robot do one particular thing or
one class of task and then it seems like
people must always come up to you and
say so okay but what about my other task
okay you know you can fold a sock or
stack a cup how about you know my dishes
that frustrating is that a challenge is
it interesting I think it's interesting
and also a huge challenge I think that
it's interesting that if a person sees a
robot doing something that seems very
capable they assume that the robot can
do all sorts of other capable things
it's a huge challenge because that's
actually not the case when we think
about babies and their social cognition
we actually start from the idea that
they have a notion of what an agent is
an agent is something that's
self-propelled that has its own internal
States like goals and uh beliefs and so
it's very natural to imagine that when
you see a you know a seemingly called
propulsive uh action by a robot you know
you're thinking hey I this thing has a
desire it has a goal it's accomplishing
it with its so what if I give it a
different goal why couldn't it do that
um they call it promiscuous
generalization about agents right I I
think that the electrical outlet looks
like a face I think that my computer's
mad at me and so so I think it you know
the Big Challenge actually is to stop
people from doing that and to recognize
limitations where there are some where
we bring to bear our knowledge sometimes
incredibly quickly to parse an uncertain
image so uh our experiences go all the
way down to our very first impressions
of the sensory signal I like that
description because it conveys how much
complexity there is to these really
basic tasks that we're doing is there a
definition for the simple tasks that we
do versus things that are more complex
like playing chess
I guess I like to think about this you
know hierarchical Cascade you know where
at first you know Vision starts with the
sensory signal and parses it to
gradually more complex units I think it
does make sense to talk about lower
level meaning closer to sensation and
perception and action uh and higher
level meaning more deliberative more
mediated by memory and language and
judgment that notion of hierarchy is
really interesting because it is these
higher level things like playing chess
for example that we that are easier for
AI systems and the reason why they're
easier is that we're providing the
abstraction for the system already when
when we give it the the game of chess to
an AI system we abstract away all the
challenges of like picking up pieces and
moving them and we say okay there's this
board of however many boxes on it and
you just need to figure out
um within that very narrow small world
what to do
but handling and learning what those
abstractions should be and handling
everything from low-level sensory inputs
to that higher level processing is
really really hard our impression that
it's purely discreet and symbolic might
be just that might be an impression
because we talk about it in language and
actually the fact that it's connected up
to all these perception and sensation
action systems means that it's probably
grounded in a more continuous set of
representations I wonder is there going
to be a point where what you really want
to know is what are the experiences that
a human has debroy's human speech-owned
project his idea was well I need the
exact data that my son gets in order to
train my robot to be like my son or do
you think that we're going to end up in
a world that's more like the large
language models and that'll have to do I
suspect that we'll start by doing
whatever is most convenient because
that's whatever we can get but I think
that for robots to be capable alongside
humans in a world with humans I think
that we may need to actually use
Human Experience human learning to
inform how robots learn if we want them
to follow the same kind of mistake
pattern as humans so that humans can
interpret robots and humans can
understand what robots will will and
will not do
AI systems and Robotics are starting to
play a larger role in our everyday lives
despite the fact that they're playing
this larger role many people don't have
a full understanding of the limitations
of these systems and I hope that through
these conversations you gained a better
understanding of where the limitations
of these systems are and what the future
might look like